Okay the answer to this question, the options
that would result in a frameshift mutation are the
first, the second and the last. Now this was
a little bit tricky. I was trying to be
a little deceitful on you here because the
position of the insertion or deletion makes no difference.
So you can ignore it. What we care about
is when we actually have the insertion. Or deletion
are we shifting our frame by a multiple of three or not? If we're shifting
by a multiple of 3, 6, 9 then we are going to keep everything down from the
insertion and deletion in frame it's still going
to be the same set of three letters,
the same codons all the way down. But
if we insert one letter, delete one letter,
insert two letters, or delete two letters, its going to throw
off everything downstream to a different frame. Same thing is
true of four letters, or five letters, or seven letters,
or eight letters. Anything that's not a multiple of three is
going to cause a frame-shift mutation. If you're having trouble understanding
the idea of a frameshift, try to think about it
like this very simple sentence here. The dog can eat
and run, is made up of words with only three letters
in them. If we were forced to read words
as sets of three letters And let's say I
deleted this letter right here. The e in eat.
Then we'd end up with the dog can ata
ndr un. Right we can't read this. This doesn't
make sense anymore. We're out of frame. Whereas if
we had just deleted the whole word eat we would end up with the dog can and run.
And sure, it doesn't make a whole lot of sense to have the
e removed, but at least all of these are words, and they make
sense, and it gives semblance to the original sequence. This is what makes
frame shifts so dangerous. Is because
frame shifts throw off everything else downstream.